Stress, in general, comes in a few different
forms- acute, episodic, and chronic.
Acute stress can be very beneficial to you.
Have you ever come face to face with a rabid
puma?
If so, the ability of your body to react quickly
can be very beneficial.
Too much stress, like in the case of episodic
or chronic, can lead to a host of psychological
and medical problems.
So what exactly is happening in the body when
you get stressed?
Stress begins when the danger is perceived.
The signal is initially sent to an area of
the brain called the amygdala; this almond-shaped
grouping of neurons processes the information,
and if it senses danger, sends a distress
signal to your hypothalamus.
The hypothalamus plays a critical role in
keeping the body’s many systems in a state
of homeostasis- basically, acting as a connector
between the endocrine system and the autonomic
nervous system.
This connection regulates the body’s many
requirements, maintaining them in a state
of equilibrium, including things like body
temperature, sleep cycles, sex drive, blood
pressure, heart rate, thirst, production of
digestive juices, and in the case of stress,
stimulating your sympathetic nervous system.
Commonly known as your fight or flight nervous
system, when the amygdala sends its distress
signal to the hypothalamus, the hypothalamus
responds by sending a message down your autonomic
nerves to your adrenal glands.
Located above your kidneys, these glands immediately
send out a hormone called epinephrine, sometimes
referred to as adrenaline.
This hormone also belongs to a class of neurotransmitters
(the things that allow your nerves to communicate
with each other) called catecholamines.
Epinephrine isn’t the only catecholamine
released in response to stress.
Dopamine and norepinephrine are also secreted.
Together, these neurotransmitters do several
things within the brain.
For instance, they cause the release of a
small protein called Neuropeptide S., which
decreases sleep and increases alertness, sometimes
giving you sense of anxiety.
They also affect memory by suppressing short-term
memory, while simultaneously signaling your
hippocampus to store the information in your
long-term memory.
This allows you to react quickly, but makes
it difficult to perform intellectual tasks
and interferes in social skills and behaviors.
Your body’s other responses to these catecholamines
are both complex and immediate.
Your blood vessels begin constricting, while
simultaneously your heart rate increases.
Your breathing rate increases, at the same
time small airways in your lungs expand.
Blood sugar is released from the many stored
areas of the body supplying the energy needs.
The result is an increase in blood and oxygen
being pumped to the many muscles and organs
of the body.
(Very critical if trying to bob-and-weave
to avoid that crazy-cat!)
Some studies suggest your blood-flow may increase
by 300-400%.
If all this seems like it would take way too
long to happen in a beneficial way, never
fear (pun intended).
The reactions by your amygdala and hypothalamus
are so fast the neurotransmitters and hormones
start their cascade-of-security before the
visual centers of the brain have even processed
the information it just received!
(Nature’s way of giving you a head start
when faced with the sudden on-slot of a carnivorous-creature!)
Your hypothalamus causing your adrenal glands
to release catecholamines is only a small
part of the stress response.
The body reacts to stress, fear, and worry
in a much more all-encompassing way.
Known as your HPA axis, this stress response
involves a connection between your hypothalamus,
pituitary, and your adrenal glands.
Once the instinctual reactions caused by catecholamines
begin causing you to fight or flight, other
hormonal signals continue giving you all the
benefits needed to maintain your panic-like
state.
At the same time catecholamines are released,
your hypothalamus also begins secreting corticotropin-releasing
factor.
This hormone then attaches to your pituitary
gland and causes it to release adrenocorticotropic
hormone.
Once in your circulatory system, it attaches
to your adrenal cortex, causing the release
of Glucocorticoids, primarily Cortisol.
Cortisol is a steroid hormone.
Its primary functions include increasing blood
sugar, suppressing your immune system, and
aiding in the metabolism of fats, proteins
and carbohydrates.
It’s also important in regulating several
body systems including the heart, lungs, circulation,
metabolism, immune system and skin.
Cortisol also reduces the effects of parts
of the immune system, thereby allowing white
blood cells and other molecules to propagate
in areas where injury will most likely occur,
like your skin and lymph nodes.
The activation of your fight or flight nervous
system also reduces the effects of your parasympathetic
nervous system, commonly known as your rest-and-digest
nervous system.
The consequence is a reduction in the effects
of your digestive system.
You might also get a dry mouth and throat
caused by blood-flow being diverted to more
essential areas of the body.
The resulting skin responses include cool,
clammy, sometimes sweaty skin.
Your scalp will also tighten causing some
hair to stand up.
As you can see by this tour of the science
behind what’s happening in your body when
you feel stress, if you needed your body to
fight off a crazy-cat, these responses can
be lifesaving.
However, problems arise when these responses
happen consistently throughout our lives,
or when the stress is perceived and not actual.
As previously mentioned, the stress response
is activated when there is a real, or perceived
threat to homeostasis.
They can also be external or internal.
Real external stresses can be things like
that mad-mouser, painful stimuli, or stressful
psychological environments such as poor working
conditions, unhappy marriages, or when one
is having financial problems.
Real internal stressors can be things like
infection, illness, or inflammation.
Some studies have shown perceived stress,
like when simply thinking or focusing on those
real stressful situations, or continually
rehashing stresses from the past, cause the
same cascade of hormone release as actual
stress.
Your endocrine glands appear to be unable
to differentiate between an outside influence,
and the memory induced influences caused by
simply thinking about upsetting things.
Does post-traumatic stress sound familiar?
Now that you know what effects stress has
on the body, imagine those same responses,
such as overexertion of your cardiovascular
system, on a consistent basis.
(Thus why chronic stress is a risk factor
for heart attacks and strokes.)
In addition, the perpetual high levels of
cortisol causes impaired cognition, increase
in abdominal fats, rapid weight gain and a
lowered immune system- no surprise then that
chronic stress is also a risk factor for diabetes,
coronary artery disease, and why it increases
your chance of getting sick.
Chronic stress has also been shown to be a
risk factor for countless other health problems,
such as depression, insomnia, anxiety, irritable
bowel syndrome, substance abuse, sexual and
reproductive dysfunctions, headaches and unexplained
muscle and joint pain.
Now that you know the cause, how do you get
rid of stress?
Simple on the surface but often difficult
to implement, the cure is just to remove or
reduce the stressful input.
Of course, it’s easy to say “I’m going
to quit my stressful job,” but homelessness
and the inability to buy food is also extremely
stressful!
A much more practical way to get rid of stress
in many cases is to find a way to get rid
of the harmful hormones and metabolites created
by the response.
How do you do that?
The body already has a natural way to settle
down after a stressful encounter; it begins
stimulating your parasympathetic nervous system.
This “rest and digest” system gets activated
when, you guessed it, you rest or you begin
digesting the food you just ate.
As you can imagine, if you’re thinking about
stressful situations all day, you’re brain
and body aren’t really resting.
Strategies to combat chronic stress should
include ways to promote relaxing- things like
meditation, deep breathing exercises, muscle
relaxation exercises, making time for recreation,
and message therapy.
Even owning a pet has been shown to reduce
stress.
Sex is also a great way to stimulate your
parasympathetic nervous system.
For the ladies, eating around 40g of dark
chocolate has been shown to reduce perceived
stress.
If you’re a particularly adventurous person,
maybe combine a few of these- stare at your
purring cat while breathing deeply and sucking
on dark chocolate at the same time your partner
gives you a massage with a happy ending…
though maybe towards the end make the cat
leave- you staring at it or it at you at such
a time is a little creepy.
If your personality tends towards excessive
emotional responses to everyday things- screaming
at the cars around you in a traffic jam because
somehow that will make it move faster- countless
studies have shown we can train our bodies
to respond differently in those situations
through behavioral therapy.
If relaxing just isn’t part of your daily
routine, there’s another scientifically
proven method to reduce excess cortisol in
your body while giving you a boatload of other
health benefits- Exercise!
(For a good ultra-science based, non-gimmicky,
simple place to start, see Bigger, Leaner,
Stronger (for guys) or Thinner, Leaner, Stronger
(for girls).
I can’t recommend these highly enough.
So much health and fitness myth debunking
and good science packaged in a relatively
quick, easy read.)
While exercise forces the body to increase
cortisol levels due to our bodies perceiving
this deviation from homeostasis as stress,
regular exercise trains the body to reduce
the amount of cortisol release when exposed
to stress.
For example, if you begin running at a 15
minute mile pace, your body will release the
appropriate amount of cortisol for that experience.
As you continue getting in better shape, less
cortisol is needed to perform the same task.
When you come across stressful encounters
in other aspects of your life, less cortisol
is released in response to that input.
The effect isn’t limited to people who exercise.
Several studies have shown those who regularly
are more active, see a decrease in cortisol
release when exposed to an emotional situation
compared to those who are sedentary.
This is very similar to the results psychologists
are hoping for when they attempt desensitization
techniques- continually exposing you to your
stress in an attempt to have less of a reaction
to it.
Other things that have been shown to increase
cortisol release are caffeine, alcohol, tobacco,
sleep deprivation and irregular sleep patterns.
From this, you don’t have to be a rocket
surgeon to realize if you decrease your caffeine
intake, stop drinking so much, and get better
sleep, you will reduce the amount of cortisol
circulating around your body.
Grandma’s advice has never been more correct-
eat right, get plenty of exercise, don’t
drink or smoke, go to bed on time, and find
a way to make money doing what you love.
If grandma’s advice seems a little too tame,
you can always try the scientifically proven
method of combining sex and chocolate!